hello everyone and welcome to round 10
of the Magnus Invitational we are back
with the match anypony versus ding Lera
and this is game 3 of their match so
where we left it off a game one was a
draw then ding won game 2 and this is
now game 3 we're not gonna be showing
game 3 I'm just gonna show you the
position that happened in game 3 because
the game 3 is a bit too short to show
you but it is important for the for the
final results so we're gonna just show
you the final position of a game 3 and
then go straight into game 4
so this is what happened in Game three
in Game three nipple was on the attack
he had the white pieces and this is what
what's happening here ding has the Queen
and rook attacking this f5 pawn and
nipple goes Knight to g4 just attacks
the rook and here ding doesn't really
have much choice he has to capture the
pawn with the Queen give up the exchange
with check capture and then play this
position being in the exchange down and
the game continues with nip of course
being better however after this night
capped Knight to g4 idea attacking the
rook ding did not capture with the Queen
instead things as said I'm not gonna be
giving any exchanges here essence nipple
gave up the exchange in the previous
game and he lost terribly so I'm just
gonna play rook captures and keep my
exchange however in order to save the
exchange he blundered the game so I'm
sure you can see how nipple wins here in
case you don't - maybe even pause the
video and try to figure it out while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on supporting a tactic
that the ding missed
and for those who just wanna enjoy the
show it's just Knight of 6 check Forks
the king and the Queen and it's a game
over you lose the Queen either you move
the King and then Knight capture screen
or you capture the the night and then
Queen captures Queen so whatever you do
you lose and after of course this Knight
to f6 check being resigned the game so
neppo equalized in the match and this is
what I mean by the title it's a very
strange that and nipple misses that
Knights - Cee 7/4 now being mrs. Knight
f6 Fork are these players just
blundering much more in online chess
than they would in in over the board
chess it's not like these are blitz
games these are a 15 minute - rapid game
so you do have time and also increment
so maybe
the games are just not as intense and
maybe the players are not as careful
because there's no maybe because there's
no actual rating loss involved it's only
online rating but still it's it's hard
to say whether m't yeah definitely an
interesting question do they blunder
more online but this is actually what's
happening game 3 so on the game for
nipple equalize the match and now it's
game for whoever wins wins the match or
if it's a draw we go into Armageddon so
let's check out game 4 and we have to
use some special effects to switch the
players here there we go again
ding with the white pieces and nipple
with black so ding opens with Knight to
f3 when going for the win ding opens
with dirty we have Knight to f6
pineapple g3 and c5 now controlling the
center we have Bishop to g2 and now
Knight to c6 with castles bleeding and E
5 now so with a lot of control of the of
the d4 square and here efore ding offers
the e4 pawn and young grabs it so knife
captures on e4 but only temporarily
now you could trade everything with
knife captures and if Ivan Bishop
captures here but being first improves
rook to e1 and now Knight back to f6 we
have nine chapters on e5 and the Bishop
to e7 and there actually are a few games
in the database that reached this
position where Knight the C 3 and C 3
were played but here ding just goes for
the immediate c4 he says we're gonna be
fighting for the d5 square and okay an
epic castles and the dingos Knight to c3
with more control of the d5 square and
now Knight captures on e5 with rook
captures on e5 and e6 pushing the rope
back and rook to e1 so much like you
would have in a Sicilian defensive black
will have to struggle on how to how to
defend this d6 backwards pawn or will he
be able to push it all the way to d5 at
some point but napalm immediately
changes the character of the game by
going Bishop to e6 he goes for the c4
pawn while giving up his b7 pawn which
ding accepts Bishop captures and b7 we
have looked the b8 and now but should be
back to G 2 and now Bishop captures on
c4 so grab
that pawn and the immediate d4 making it
hard for an effort to capture on before
because if captures captures then
there's a double attack on the bishop
and on the pawn so once you move the
pawn bishop you lose the pawn and now
white would have to connect the pass
pawns on the Queen side so first a
nipple goes back Bishop to e6 and now b3
preparing to develop the dark square
bishop so the b2 pawn will not be a
target
we have worked there before now
supporting the capture on d4 so dean
captures and on c5 and said we have d
captures and c5 d captures on c5 and
ding now offers a queen trade
I mean trades Queens captures captures
and Bishop to a3 now and now instead of
going for the backwards d6 pawn now
you're gonna go for the c5 pawn so
Bishop to e3
we have rugby to be 8 and the Knight to
a4 and this is just very clean how Dean
goes after this c5 pawn so there's a
double attack on it and rook dc-8 and
they put defends it once again rook 8 2
c1 attacking it once again and now
defending it once again with Knight to
d7 just defending that c5 pawn and now
it's a very instructional how to how to
add another attacker to the c5 pawn or
better yet how to remove one of the
defenders so feel free to pause the
video and think about the positional
Luud how would you proceed here you know
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who found the dings
move congratulations on being incredibly
creative and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's Bishop to b5
here ding offer his Bishop to remove one
of the one of the defenders of the c5
pawn and if you don't capture then ding
just captures captures in the wins upon
so neppo did capture we have Bishop
captures rook captures now removing one
of the defenders while also attacking
one of the one of the defenders and
Bishop the c6 by Neville just defending
that defending that night and now of
course you part with your c5 pawn we
have Knight captures and c5 in here nay
portraits Knight captures rook captures
and we get this position where ding is
up upon and it's two points against one
on the Queen side with bishops of
opposite colors so if the rooks come off
the board nipple has
great chances budgeting of course we'll
try not not to allow the works to come
off the board so a six not allowing the
this point to be a target and now F for
you don't want to allow in a post and
Bishop to have three ideas which will
really limit the movements of the White
King inning you have to worry about all
sorts of back ranked weaknesses so f4
instead now also making room for the
King to be able to enter the game and h6
never just make some breathing room for
its King now King F to Dean starts his
King March King Bishop to b5 and now
defending the pawn also it's a this is a
very nice diagonal for this Bishop and
now kinked III being a further improves
the position of his King rook to b8 now
with some rook to death recheck ideas
but rooks eat the c7 and now adding says
I'm just gonna gobble up all of these
points as I have two pigs on the seventh
rank we have worked the d3 with check
King that a four and now not going for
any rook f8 ideas because the world
there's just this Bishop here x-ray in
the f8 square so you might just move the
rook and pick up that rook or rather you
will just be able to force more trades
and you will be you will be still up
upon so instead nipple goes for the
counter attack rook the d2 he wants to
grab some pawns here while also he might
be having some ideas with Bishop to d3
trick so rook captures on f7 he grabs a
pawn and now rook to e8 with check and
with the two rooks controlling the D and
the e-file dink has to go to the F file
and it would be a big mistake to go to
f3 because here you're just getting made
Bishop e2 check you have to go to g2 or
f2 doesn't really matter Bishop g4 check
now not allowing h3 King f1 check here
and now rook to e1 will be checkmate so
very tricky now idea by neppo doing
spots it he goes King to a5 and now
Bishop to d3 check again checking where
wording will go well not here as g4 is
the only square available to the king
but now rook captures on h2 Bishop to e2
check is also possible but King will be
very safe on h4 and then even if you go
for some g5 check fall by rook to e4
check ideas the rook can always block
with rook to f4 so instead nipple goes
for rook
chapters on h2 now Bishop to e2 check
might be a bit more dangerous but also
he allows the route chapters on g7 but
okay King to h8 the Bishop also guards
the h7 square so you don't have to worry
about any further checks but now ding
almost instantly played Bishop to d6 and
it's an extremely strong move going for
Bishop to e5 which will just destroy the
black king so here nepo finds a
beautiful idea
again Bishop to e2 not not strong
because after King a5 Bishop d3 checking
if six and you don't really have any
other ways of continuing the attack
so after this Bishop to b6 we have
looked f2 a very tricky idea by napalm
saying that ok if you go brush up the e5
now do you see what Knepper had in mind
even feel free to pause the video this
this is a good one so for those of you
who decided to pause the video
congratulations well II just on your
decision to pause the video you know
it's always nice when you want to
improve your tactics and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's rook
captures on e5 and white is getting
destroyed because after captures your
Bishop to f5 check King to h4 and our
rook to h2 is checkmate with the pawn
and the bishop and not allowing the the
White King to escape so very trick the
idea by neppo but ding doesn't fall for
it ding goes for Bishop to c5 instead he
says I'm gonna go for Bishop d4 with the
same idea but now neppo again stops it
looked the b2 now Bishop d4 will be met
with just Bishop checks and you pick up
the bishop on d4 so ding again with the
same idea Bishop b4 he's now gonna go to
c3 and attack the King from here but
neppo says no you don't look the c2 and
here doing it very happily trades at one
of the rooks we have rook captures and
c2 now of course not cat of course you
don't capture and allow this rook to
Lily live as there's some Bishop to c3
ideas here so King captures and g7 and
now rook the c7 with check and here ding
just basically trades down in turning
and where he's up to pawns but still
perhaps if if you're incredibly lucky
and the ding does something wrong maybe
you can still pull it off so King g6 but
now rook the c6 with check
the other pollen falls as well king f7
and now rook captures on h6 we have
looked at it to buy an echo and now rook
the d6 just going after that Bishop rook
to e3 and now King to h4 with Bishop to
e2 and now g4 thing starts pushing his
connected passed pawns we looked at f3
going after the pawn and now rook the d4
defending we looked back to F 2 and now
King to g5 and it was in this position
that anypony should resign the game as
he is done three pawns and of course
this is completely winning for white so
really an incredible game and III really
really enjoyed this moment where we're
doing went to Bishop to d5 it was it was
such an such an instructive idea and
just remove one of the one of the
defenders this way and then it's just
winning a clean pawn so very nice and
very nice by doing dodging all those
tricks nip nip or through them and well
it's it's basically payback for for
blundering that Queen in Game three but
yeah
ding wins the game for which means he
wins the match and if you haven't seen
it yesterday here are the standings
after 10 rounds
so being leerin in the lead followed by
Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus Carlsen well
they're tied with 11 points Fabiano
Caruana with 10 points in 4th then Maxie
Marshall agree on a pony she would 5
unease very good for and otherwise of
Fallujah with 3 and like I mentioned
yesterday
two more rounds to go anything can still
happen except for ali reza ali reza as
he's on three points he cannot reach at
the knockout fa you-know phase of the
tournament since he can only get to nine
points and Fabi is already on 10 but I
think for everyone else it is still
possible to be in the top four and go
into the knockout stage of the
tournament so that's the game and the
match I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank a Christian spring Kevin
Clark Henry's fragments are gone and
solder wall and Lakatos gear go for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you in continuing the coverage of the
Magnus Invitational until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day